proposer un regard différent sur le
handicap
mais il jeunes valides ou non ont
participé aux olympiades du vivre
ensemble
grande journée sportive samedi à
versailles
l'occasion de s'essayer à de nombreuses
disciplines connu au moins comme le
chant de barra sortent des scream avec
des armes en mousse un sport importé du
japon adapté et adaptable aux personnes
non valides
il peut être conseillé par ce qu'il fait
travailler la motricité donc pour les
personnes qui ont un handicap moteur
nous pouvons également pratiqué en
fauteuil nous avons une capacité à
adapter des armes ce sont des armes très
souples sont les armes qui peuvent être
très légère ce sont des âmes sur lequel
on développe même une pratique en
aveugle pour les non voyants avec la
possibilité au travers de clochettes de
sentir le sabre donc on a vraiment une
volonté que cette pratique aille vers le
les personnes en situation de handicap
aux côtés des apprentis samouraï du
football pour les déficients visuels
avec des ballons remplis de grenoble
tirs au but et conduite de balle animé
par des non voyants comme le prometteur
tijane inscrit seulement depuis novembre
avant de commencer je croyais que je
pouvais pas le faire mais bon ça va je
me débrouille très bien quand même
pour le moment je suis débutant dès dans
deux trois ans pas fâché avec les guides
de france venus soutenir l'événement
emmanuel petit est un sportif engagé qui
a déjà tenté de jouer au cécifoot j'ai
essayé j'ai essayé mais que si vous
voulez on a lorsque vous êtes valider
mon métier en situation d'handicap c'est
c'est très très compliqué ce massacre et
25 ans tout le monde associatif est
aussi nommément de l'handicaper même si
les mentalités ont évolué il ya encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire parce que la
ségrégation la discrimination existe
tout le temps au sein même des
différents handicaps
donc ça vous laisse présager de ce qui
peut y arriver dans la société tous les
jours avec les valides